Everybody knows a great movie when they see it,
but sometimes it's hard to put your finger on what exactly made it work.
We usually judge effective moments based on their shot, composition,
character choices, or dialogue,
but sometimes powerful thematic choices come in unexpected ways in the opening
scene of the godfather,
the light hits America in a way that makes him look like a rat,
emphasizing his portrayal of the Italian way of life.
But the most powerful moment comes later in the scene.
It took over a minute to understand that America is at odds with his Italian
identity, but for veto,
it takes us only a tiny moment to learn just as much about him.
All it took was a wave of his hand,
Like many cinematic techniques, a hand can convey a lot of visual information,
depending on the context, it can symbolize power, the unknown or affection,
and you can even see it in action. 80 years ago
In 1936 Chevrolet released a sponsored documentary film titled master hands,
showing the work that goes behind making a Chevrolet car.
The film focuses on the hands of anonymous workers as they built a car from
them.
From the master of the tool makers to the
hands that mastered.
At the end of the documentary hands clutched the newly finished car and drive
off the film, shoots the hands on the steering wheel, the same way at shot,
the hands, making the car.
And this association of hands sends a clear message to consumers.
Chevys are sold to the same blue collar hands that also make them pairing the
producers of the car with the consumers of the car.
Also supports the idea that a worker directly benefits from the work they put
in, but in 1936, the workers didn't feel that way.
The mid 1930s actually had some of the most violent worker strikes in American
history.
And labor brought back with the dome or anything.
In his article, hands off the machine historian.
Max Frazier talks about the use of hands in the art of the 1930s to symbolize
the working class.
The instincts to associate hands with the working class makes sense.
Most low paying jobs required tedious manual labor and artists saw the effect of
those jobs in people's hands in media. At the time,
there are generally two types of pants in master hands.
They show the benefits of manual labor.
They look productive and efficient helping to create a car. In the end,
in this film, hands don't challenge, their mistreatment or act on their own.
The hands are almost extensions of the machines themselves repetitive and
complacent in their singular task.
But those hands were much more oppressed than the documentary implies.
The workers, films and master hands actually went on strike the following year.
Now the hands are the second type, not working hands,
but protesting hands free to move.
As they please a hands not performing manual labor has a completely different
symbolic meaning than the working one. Instead of doing tasks for a corporation,
these hands act on their own free to do what they want.
It makes sense that these free hands became a symbol that labor parties and
communists embraced. When a free hand doesn't perform work,
it's resisting the status quo.
These two kinds of hands reflect the level of control that a person,
either their hands do what they're told like in master hands or they resist and
act on their own like during a worker strike.
And we see this dual symbolism of the hand in feature film because the hand is
such a good way to show a person acting on their own.
Self-interest a hand oftentimes represents a person's control or a lack of
control. Of course, hands and movies.
Don't always have to contain some grand symbolic meaning,
but if you approach them from this angle,
you may see some patterns in how they're used. Every human has hands.
So it's a pretty accessible symbol in popular culture that filmmakers use in a
variety of contexts. The symbolic power of hands is almost unlimited.
[Inaudible].
The force essentially functions as hand superpowers, fader chokes,
an adversary from afar with just a small pinch of his fingers and uses his hands
to stop lasers in their tracks.
The force extends the user's physical control into their environments.
Not only are you in control of yourself, but you can literally control others.
It's the ultimate way to show power. So if hands give people control,
then losing a hand, does the opposite,
loosen your hand in a star Wars film means much more because hands are such a
symbol of power without his hand,
we feel unsure if Luke will regain the same mastery over the forest that he had
earlier,
it's the total loss of control of his hands that contributes to the feeling of
defeat at the end of empire,
while Vader wants to sever Luke's powerful hand SAR on wants to empower the
hands in Lord of the rings. The most powerful tool is not a crown or a necklace.
It's a ring,
a ring empowers a person's hand in the same way that a tool raised in the air
empowers a factory worker,
but ultimately a hand wearing a ring is not a free hand.
And by creating desire for power, the ring, ironically enslaves,
not unlike the factory workers under the control of their company,
fantasy films use hands and the extension of a person's hands to show power or
the lack of it. And that includes the most popular franchise in recent memory,
like the ring and the force be infinity gauntlet gets a lot of its symbolic
strength. By focusing on the hand,
the gauntlet feels like one of the most intimidating weapons put to film because
it extends the control of a hand into control of the fabric of the entire
universe. It's certainly cool that Santos can use the gauntlet to control moons.
You thrown her moon at me and I'm going to lose it, but we see it.
How are the most when he does so much more with such a little gesture,
with a simple snap of his fingers, he alters the course of the entire.
Universe. It's.
Basically the opening of the godfather on steroids,
both banjos and veto essentially use their hands in the same way before Vito
speaks.
He gives a command with his hands to get America a drink with such a small
gesture. He can control the world around him.
The hand movement shows Vito's power precisely because the gesture is so small
by placing the hand in the foreground,
it dominates the scene and conveys visual authority. When Vito does his gesture,
America is literally in the Palm of his hands.
Paul Thomas Anderson uses a similar method in there will be blood.
You often sensors the frame on the hand to subtly communicate important bits of
information while a different film might cut to closeups of faces or the map
Anderson has the confidence to stick to this wide shot and use hands to direct
our eyes. And if anyone's hands command attention throughout the scene,
it's Daniels,
he doesn't even have to directly face the camera to command to the screen.
When he goes to shake Paul's hand, his hand cuts across the frame,
preventing Eli from leaving.
This motion feels aggressive despite just being a handshake.
It's a small example of Daniel's manipulative personality disguised as just the
simple work of a businessman throughout the rest of the film.
Daniel's hands are a main focus for his character. He regularly.
Grabs and slaps.
And he always does. So to express his authority,
the film follows the power struggle between him and Eli.
So it makes sense that they use their hands to attempt to take control.
In this scene.
Daniel asserts his authority and Eli stands by looking powerless with his hands,
a little lower than the center of the frame. In many ways,
they are like the hands of America. Also tightly contained.
The one big difference though,
is that America's hands tremble and move around randomly while Eli remained
steady.
It turns out that Eli was only holding back and we see the true power of his
hands. When he leaves church here,
he has the authority to point grab and even slap Daniel.
At this point in the film, Eli has just as much power, but of course,
it's Daniel who wins in the end. And once again, his hands dominate the frame,
right?
Drink your milkshake.
But thinking about hands only as a symbol of a power dynamic sells them short.
Many of the most famous hands in movie history don't necessarily fit into that
idea.
The problem is that we've been thinking of hands as an extension of the power of
a human, but what if the hand isn't even human in the first place?
And what if the hand isn't even attached to anything?
There's a common horror trope of the severed hand that still moves.
There's something frightening about a hand without its master,
possibly because it literally has a mind of its own.
If a hand represents control,
then losing control of your hands would be the ultimate loss of agency.
Unusual hands make their way into the horror genre because we all have an
understanding of what a hand should be. And it's the part of our body.
We use the most for everyday tasks and understanding of what's normal and common
gives the filmmaker the opportunity to show that someone or something is
abnormal in district nine,
wikis starts turning into an alien after accidentally spraying himself with a
mysterious liquid. So which body part becomes alien first.
[Inaudible].
And to as expected his hands changing, the NC can now fire alien weapons,
not only do his hands represent the abnormal,
but they still show the classic power dynamic ITI introduces the idea that an
alien hand doesn't have to be evil before ITI aliens almost always appeared as
the villain and to their foreign hands meant they were a threat to the norm,
but each uses his hands to show his trust in Elliot life King Kong.
It challenges the assumption that a foreign hand has to be an evil one.
We've been ignoring the most important reason for hands.
The kind of hands we hopefully see most often in our everyday lives. The trust.
Hands are an easy way to visualize cooperation.
It goes against the idea that hands are used to dominate a situation.
They can also show cooperation and affection, hand touching.
Is it always cold and power hungry? Like the kiss of death,
a movie like call me by your name,
feel so warm and loving because characters regularly touch and hold each other.
And not just in a romantic way.
Elio's dad speaks to him in a surprisingly tender way about his relationship and
ask the scene fades out.
He reaches out to touch it in contrast to the doubt in American beauty never
touches anybody.
Once he finally does it's in such an awkward and unfulfilling way,
or maybe the dad's hand is too controlling. Oh, my thin old,
my fan Marlin and finding Nemo has to accept that he can never entirely control
and protect NEMA.
We see as conflict manifested literally when he holds onto the whale's tongue,
but instead of a hand, it's a flipper.
[Inaudible].
So hands really are the visible part of the brain.
If some people literally use their hands as a language,
I don't think it's much of a stretch to think that filmmakers can use hands to
communicate complicated ideas.
Control good, or the lack of it,
the foreign or the familiar.
The loving, or the sassy ones.
It's definitely a weird way to look at a scene, but who knows?
Maybe one day it'll come in handy. I'm not sure what to do with my hands. Oh,
it'd be good. Just hold them down by your side. Yeah. Great.
Of course the symbolic history of hands goes back much further in other art
forms.
There's a fascinating history behind the study of hands and art during the
Renaissance era artists like Michelangelo and DaVinci had a fixation on the
anatomy of the hand that was both scientific and aesthetic.
I definitely recommend checking out the documentary,
the Renaissance factor because it goes into details beyond the scope of this
video. It's a fascinating watch that outlines the advances in art,
in science that prompted this focus on anatomy. You can watch it on curiosity,
straight curiosity.
Stream's newly expanded library has thousands of titles that will send you down
the rabbit hole on topics like art, science, and history. Go to curiosity,
stream.com/. Now you see it and enter the promo code.
Now you see it when prompted during the signup process,
your membership is completely free for the first 30 days with our code,
plus it helps us out too. And as always thanks to our patrons for your support.
If you're considering supporting the channel,
check out our Patrion to get early access to videos and behind the scenes
content. Thanks.
For watching.